foreign
picture this
you have the opportunity to own a
beautiful home in a historic
neighborhood with deep cultural routes
designed by some of the best urban
planners in the world all near Charming
waterfront city
you'd want to live here right
but what if I told you that this home
was in an area of Baltimore called the
black butterfly
we're block after block of these
beautiful historic row homes sit vacant
and are negatively valued
meaning that the cost to repair each
home is actually more than what the
market says it's worth
somehow the market must be broken right
what's going on here
I've been studying the way housing
markets work or don't work for the last
decade
I started my career in investment
Finance on Wall Street
but when my hometown on the outskirts of
New York City began to be gentrified it
pushed me into becoming a housing
advocate
I learned more about the racist policies
mandated by federal and local
governments like redlining in urban
renewal that gutted once thriving black
communities across the country
and prevented black citizens from
Building Wealth through homeownership
these communities typically face two
trajectories
the first is a downward spiral where
political and financial disinvestment
causes hyper vacancy and Decay that
pushes people out of a neighborhood
big Banks see this Exodus as
confirmation that these neighborhoods
are risky
defeated
unredeemable
and so without investment
the cycle of distress continues
the second trajectory is gentrification
where developers are able to capitalize
off of this distress
by buying undervalued properties pumping
money into them without considering the
needs or wants of Legacy residents
and then renting or reselling them at
much much higher costs causing
displacement
so my question became
can we do development without
displacement is there another way
I quit my job on Wall Street and moved
to Baltimore the city that birthed
redlining with the single suitcase to
find out
my first inclination was to meet with
investors
and you know to raise funds for my idea
and I was literally laughed out of the
room
they said that my idea was impossible
and that we would build homes that would
sit empty for lack of demand
but I knew in my heart of hearts that
that wasn't true
unexpectedly in that moment being
rejected by investors was the most
important moment in my journey
because I realized that we didn't need
big institutions to affirm the value of
our communities
we'd affirm our own value through social
capital
and so I started my non-profit parody
which creates upfront demand for
homeownership opportunities in
neighborhoods experiencing hyper vacancy
simply by tapping into existing social
networks
what started as an idea from just one
has grown into a collective movement of
eight then 19 and now 44 future
homeowners all through Word of Mouth
and we have a wait list over thank you
thank you
we now have a wait list of over 100
people wanting to join our intentional
community
like Yolanda
who's ready to buy a home to leave a
legacy for her daughters
or Janae a fourth generation baltimorean
whose father vividly remembers the
demolition of black homes to make way
for a highway to nowhere
Ico whose family left West Baltimore
when he was just a baby but now is
coming back home to his Origins to be
part of the revitalization
and Medina who like me came to Baltimore
from New York to settle down and build a
future
there are three key reasons why our work
is transformational
the first is that we are leading the
purchase and renovation of dozens of
decades-long abandoned buildings and
we're selling them at deeply affordable
price points
the second is that we not only support
our home buyers to become credit
qualified and mortgage approved but
we're creating the opportunity for folks
to build deep social bonds and
friendships with their future Neighbors
and three we're preventing the
displacement of Legacy residents by
ensuring that they have the resources
that they need to stay in their homes
and transfer their wealth to the Next
Generation
we're we're healing the social fabric of
the neighborhood as we're rebuilding the
built environment
contrary to the dominant narrative there
absolutely is demand for housing and
historically black neighborhoods
devastated by racist policy
we've tapped into a hunger and appetite
hiding in the blind spots of the
traditional Capital markets
remember those folks that laughed me out
of the room
well we have more within just two years
time we now have more demand for our
homes than we have homes we're sold out
and so can we do development without
displacement
we absolutely can
thank you
[Applause]